boa tarde a todos
bom a gente já viu um outro casal aqui
ela é a minha metade na laranja
só que a metade da laranja pedagógica eu
só age e essa é nossa a nossa muito
distintas 70 escolas em 1985 e de lá
saiu mas seja qual a onu ou como a
família é toda de professores e isso foi
mobilizador da minha profissão
a minha professora foi minha prima
apesar disso e vamos abordá-lo jia fazer
o assunto é realmente obrigado à minha
mãe para a docência que constitui a
católica seja paga pelas parcerias que
contribuam com um caminho e pelos bons
exemplos
eu fui pra melhor elogia a minha escola
foi na época da ditadura ea única
lembrança que eu recuperei foi o desfile
de 7 de setembro
enfim eu me levo a grade de horários e
que dizia e você aumenta nessa época
educação moral
fica foi falava isso eu tive técnicas
domésticas e técnicas agrícolas
essa é que eu aceito a escola apesar
disso eu é um roubo na que vinha na
média
aproveito a z acesso e no primeiro a
prova da escola
eu gostava dos colegas do rei tá
querendo dar a ideia canção física
bom eu jogo assim 1980 press
eu entrei na escola em 1989 e lavar a
casa também não sair mais
seja como a lona ou como educadora
diferente da ana
eu era uma bola que adorava das melhores
notas que fazer tudo certinho aliança
dourada pela pessoa e eu também
três delas não fui fazendo mistério eu
fiz o ensino médio e no ensino médio e
encontrei uma professora e cativou com o
fazer sem tela graças a ela
hoje eu sou professora ela me inspirou e
graças às redes sociais também eu pude
reencontrar essa professora e você não
imagina a felicidade vai poder conversar
com ela novamente foi motivo de orgulho
e assim eu espero que seja os alunos
também é diferente
bem eu não fui à minha família a gente
não tinha
pessoas eu fui a primeira professora da
maneira como eu fazer você com o meu
jeito de da aula eu também já tiver
alguém a minha irmã
dez anos mais nova do que eu vou gostar
pedagogia e hoje vive a grata surpresa
de poder integrar a entregar a ela
o canudo no dia da palavra eu tive
muitas lembranças da minha alfabetização
quando a gente estava montando essa tal
eu preencher muitas vêm as coisas
nocivas e wolley 8 a olhão em coelhos de
páscoa o ladin de um barracão quem outra
vez foi legal na minha sala
fomos os colegas fazem umas dessas
atividades naquela folhas eram
biografados que tinham aquele cheiro
característico de álcool costuma liberar
extinto na vila
e não é bom até quem festa baiana aline
rolando a bola
ae sabia estar bêbado e até gente cria
perfis para levar de tudo isso gente
a escola legal muito carinho as minhas
professoras e dos meus colegas
a gente bem assim
a f 1 mudou o mundo
nós somos de gerações diferentes mais de
dez anos de diferença e foi a mesma e
isso para nós é importante demais
a tecnologia finalmente chegou r 1
bilhão olha foi trocado pela foto
copiadora é também chegou o pai de
tecnologia é os réus projetores e as
lâminas foram substituídos pelos
projetores e temos mais o quadro negro
que era verde pelo quadro que chegaram
também os laboratórios de informática
com os computadores de toda essa
evolução a escola continua do mesmo
jeito
essa é uma sala de aula do século 19 e
olhando para a escola e não muda
o seu redor ao se resolvemos parar de
reclamar lá e fomos pensar alternativas
escócia diferente em 2014
nós encontramos eu tive a graça
presidente recebeu josé esta instituição
já estava trabalhando e nós descobrimos
as mesmas condições pedagógicas de
crianças de educação e de importância da
família na escola
formamos uma toalha e fomos procurar em
2010 ante o dado é mais adequado
parceiros inseparáveis personagem dele
se engajado em cumprir até mesmo na
cilada
agora eu tenho que ter a tarefa quando a
gente começou a escolher um personagem
meu cel d e esconde lá jamais
considerando a obra maravilhosa e é
honesta e verdadeira inseparável muito
ea gente curtiu as nossas ideias e as
crianças estavam conosco tirou nossas
ideias e os pais e também estavam
famosos conosco curtiram também ea gente
começou a pensar então estava no mundo
cheio de confecções e compartilhamento
de 10 e por minha consciência gente não
compartilha porque a gente passa assim
por que não compartilhar e editar
o mundo aquilo que a gente estava
fazendo dentro da nossa sala de aula
a idéia dessa parceria deu tão certo que
a gente começou a pensar então esse
projeto pudesse ser chique ponto de
igual pra todo mundo do mesmo
do mesmo jeito e ao mesmo tempo fazendo
um movimento dessa escola e é a mesma
desde o nosso tempo a chegar à bola
eu espero que vocês estejam furiosos que
a gente estava na sala de aula se salvou
da república não é nada ilegal
não é nada muito menos perigoso apenas
50 crianças de sete anos na mesma sala
de aula
eu tenho certeza que se fosse casar
geral fez a diferença
é uma loucura para isso o projeto
educação compartilhada e surgiu da fifa
coisa quando nós tínhamos duas turmas
mas aí foi reativado em 2015
nós entendemos que todos a vertentes de
jeitos diferentes em contextos
diferentes e com estilos diferentes não
é preciso a inclusão virmos dizer que
nós temos que olhar pra gente de
qualidade desse jeito porque todos nós
somos diferentes
duas professoras no mesmo espaço
compartilham prática pedagógica
refletivo olhando para esses alunos
pelo potencial de cada um teria uma
outra organização curricular
faça o que acontece essa outra
organização curricular bom processo a 50
crianças elas são divididas em cinco
grupos de trabalho
nós não temos 50 classes a nossa sala de
aula ou seja a turma passa por cinco
estações de aprendizagem ao longo da
tarde as ações contemplam as diversas
áreas do conhecimento então a gente tem
a sensação que envolvem raciocínio
lógico matemático
a ação envolve a criatividade agitação
que envolve a linguagem a estação que
envolve a leitura ea estação envolve um
regime porque o registro ainda faz parte
da escola apesar de toda a tecnologia
para ela isso em alguns dias da semana a
gente ainda tem a estação da frança
a intenção do uso das tecnologias e o
que mais respondem ao encanto não seja
mobilizador dessa aprendizagem
falando em uso das tecnologias nós
usamos muito as tecnologias possam ver
os vídeos com eles de leitura de 500 da
nossa tarde ea gente também utiliza
games
sim os games estão na nossa sala de aula
além disso ter vivido esses vídeos que
nós fizemos e as fotos desses momentos
da tarde a rede social permite que a
gente vive em grupos fechados
e nós temos um grupo fechado na nossa
turma ei
as famílias nossos alunos estão nesse
grupo e lá a gente possa tudo que faz
confiança sejam fotos ou vídeos
os pais acompanham praia começo em tempo
real aqui ele está acontecendo na nossa
sala de aula
hoje tá muito na hora de dizer à família
não na escola lhe sobra se não andar
juntos enquanto que os pais são
convidados a participar das moedas da
escola ea escola escuta esses pais
pra mim esse título me fazer presente
ela desistir pn 7 ela tem que se sentir
parte do processo de educação dos seus
filhos mesmo que eles estejam na escola
a família precisa ser ouvida e convidada
para citar a todo momento e quais os
resultados obtidos até agora com certeza
projeto podem ser os olhos e não docente
e oportunizou anp ou aprendizagem desses
lotes mobilizou a estudar mais o quadro
organizou a gente planeja planeja
planeja de novo que planeja planeja é
isso que a gente queria mais claro e dá
trabalho mas é inspirador e o mais
importante do projeto ou portuguesa
protagonismo dessas crianças pequenas
eles fazem as funções no final da semana
a gente fala assembléia outro sonho que
dava certo
em sansão botão e tudo mais que eles
podem adaptar colaborar para o bem de
todos
e se a gente fica pensando né
é bom fazer aqui em casa se tratava o
mesmo exemplo vocês podem estar a gente
selecionou dois exemplos para vocês e
para que a gente repense o nosso
trabalho em dia tá é isso que a gente é
como por exemplo quando um aluno já
presentes em prof
mas o que eu aprendo copiando 44 anos
disse sim aproveitar aquele autor do
livro da caixa preta que fazer uma
relação uma metáfora uma medusa porque a
pedra rosa também tem que ficar as
pessoas né
crianças de sete anos de uma escola
pública
a gente acredita nessa sala da escola
pública e de qualidade porque porque nós
queremos
e esse seja um sujeito o futuro
não adianta a mudança começará apenas
por nós professores
nós queremos que esses alunos sejam os
jogadores e eles pressionem os modelos
existentes e que em outros novos
diferentes e por 100 a transformação
isso a escola precisa ser diferente
nós alcançamos os índices desejáveis nas
avaliações jogar sal é muito mais que
nós podemos observar atitudes para o
futuro das crianças
o nosso incite violência zero a
colaboração essas crianças é linda ea
alegria com a conquista ea toya dos
colegas é fantástica
nós queremos compartilhar e educadores
que queiram transformar a estação nove
erros que antes precisa divulgar
práticas inovadoras ea gente que pensa
como agente e quer mudar essa educação
sou nós temos que fazer essa mudança
nós conseguimos criar um espaço feliz
pra nós e com os ovos numa mensagem de
nata e que há várias formas já ter de se
apresentam numa sala de aula
comemorativa em que todos ensina em
todos os atletas é que amanhã que a
gente faz o caminho e você deve estar se
perguntando por que eu espero nesse
projeto porque vejo que é uma escola
diferente mas falando você viva aleph
feliz
um dos alunos como para nós as
professoras a gente queria ter um
movimento dessa escola e mostrar que sim
é possível ensinar e aprender com outras
possibilidades mas ao mesmo tempo você
saiba se perguntando e eu entendi lisboa
a personalização da educação aí fica
são as novas tendências são tendências e
nós estamos até usar isso mas falhou no
nosso contexto pra nossa sala de aula e
ver o que é possível de fazer para votar
essa escola que é a mesma desde nosso
filho
a gente teve que fazer escolhas ao longo
do caminho é claro a gente podia
continuar a fazer do mesmo jeito mas a
gente não via isso a gente quis fazer de
nós tivemos alguns contratempos no
sistema com a gestação e foi detectada
continua no g 16
o projeto questionamos fotos fazer
educação e aos outras possibilidades
gastamos a nossa sala de água
falhamos pra fora no coro da escola tudo
aquilo que a gente vinha fazendo isso
pra não ser muito significativo foi a
forma que a gente encontrou de mobilizar
o espaço onde nós estávamos e isso para
nós não tem dimensão de conseguir um
espaço fazer o momento pra que ele venha
com fora
o pai ainda vai estar aqui hoje
ela disse que eu gosto muito e sei que o
oe contagia e design contrário a
qualquer proposta busca de parceiros
eles vivem o peso das responsabilidades
e aliviam o carrinho
sérgio sejam os vocês professores dessa
mudança somos nós
eles espalharam excelentes e para
encenar em uma fase do gravatá que a
gente gosta ruim e ele também ficou
muito feliz a gente está aqui
compartilhando a nossa experiência ea
frase dele diz mais ou menos assim não
vai esquecer de compartilhar pois aquilo
que você viver é uma experiência que
pode inspirar e é se mexer passar ainda
não saiu do lugar
muito obrigado
ae